what's up all this is david ahmadi
speaking for randolph ramsay the new
nintendo switch oled is almost out with
its release date of october 8th only a
matter of days away i recently got some
hands-on time with this new version
during a preview session with the
upcoming metroid dread and i'm sure the
question you're all asking is the same
is the nintendo switch oled version
which at 350 dollars is 50 dollars more
expensive than the base switch version
is it worth it right now that's not
something that can be answered
definitively especially as i only had
about an hour of playtime with the new
console my initial impression of it so
far though is that it is worth it if
only for that bright beautiful oled
screen if you already have a switch it
may not be worth the upgrade but if this
is your very first one then the oled
model looks like it represents the best
version of this particular piece of
nintendo hardware so what do you get for
that extra 50 that the oled version is
asking for as the name suggests the main
difference is in the oled screen which
at 7 inches is significantly larger than
the current switch's 6.2 inch screen
it's immediately noticeable too with the
oled screen having a thinner surrounding
bezel one other major noticeable
difference is the unit's kickstand while
the existing switch featured that dinky
little leg at the back of the unit the
oled version's kickstand extends across
the entire back of the console that
means it is way way more stable to use
in tabletop mode the new kickstand's
angle can be adjusted which means you
not only have more stability but the
ability to easily change up your viewing
angles the unit's speakers too have been
improved and they sounded louder and
crisper than what the vanilla switch
could output direct comparisons though
were hard to discern as i wasn't able to
do direct side-by-side comparisons of
the different switches the other changes
to the switch are much less visible and
amount to some needed quality of life
changes the switch oled is slightly
longer and slightly heavier but
certainly not enough to be noticeable
when i was holding it in my hands it now
has 64 gigabytes of internal storage
versus the old switch is 32 gigabytes
and the location of the sd card slot has
been moved to the back of the oled
version behind the kickstand the new
dock now has a built-in lan port which
removes the need for an external dongle
and yes the oled switch as with all
switches now thanks to a recent update
now supports bluetooth connectivity for
headphones and
that's really it the oled switch
features the same processor as the
existing model which means there
shouldn't be any real difference when it
comes to performance with games there's
no stated difference in battery life and
there's also no difference in what the
new switch can output to a tv which
means both versions are capped at 1080p
what it boils down to is all of the
improvements to this model are really
designed around improving the handheld
experience now as i mentioned we weren't
able to do side-by-side comparisons so
it's hard to say definitively just how
much better the new oled screen is but
during my time with metroid dread it
certainly looked amazing all of the
features you've come to expect from oled
screens darker blacks popping color and
outstanding contrast were certainly
evident and metroid dread was an ideal
game to show off thanks to the look of
its moody levels the added screen real
estate was definitely a large plus too
so back to that original question is the
nintendo switch oled worth the purchase
well you'll have to wait for gamespot's
official review of the system before we
have a definitive answer if you're not
in the market for a new switch then i'd
probably hold off and see if nintendo
does come up with a much improved
version a little later however i can
tell you that as someone who has a
beaten up scratch lawn switch i'd
certainly want to buy this new oled
version and that 50 premium seems like
an acceptable price to pay for this
decent upgrade
[Music]
[Music]
you